most Peters work on a flat canvas but
not Alexa Meade I paint on people and
three-dimensional objects I do it in a
way that will make them look like a
two-dimensional painting when
photographed looking at my work it feels
ambiguous about where things lie in
space and it's hard to wrap your head
around the dimensionality of it
especially when you're just looking at a
two-dimensional image in video you can
start to see some of the depth cues with
parallax and the movement of the camera
revealing more angles of the painting
Meade calls her work reverse trouble
because instead of painting on a
two-dimensional surface to trick the eye
and brain into seeing a
three-dimensional object she's
flattening three dimensions into - this
isn't forced perspective it works from
every possible angle that you could
approach it I paint on the backsides of
things I paint on the underside of
tables every surface within a scene will
be covered in a mask of paint and this
mask of paint will reference what's
directly below it
it'll exaggerate it or accentuate some
minor details or flaws
that will give it that painterly edge
and really change the way that you would
perceive depth within the scene
interestingly Meade never intended to
become an artist I didn't know that I'd
end up being a painter I'd studied
politics and that was my life path in my
dream Meade's work has been exhibited
around the world including at the
Smithsonian National Portrait Gallery
she's worked on advertising campaigns
for mercedes-benz Ralph Lauren and
Lacroix watches and yes those are her
brush strokes on pop singer ariana
grande I painted ariana grande for her
God is a woman music video that was
inspired by a collaboration I had done
with Sheila band red painted Sheila's
body put her in a pool of milk and the
colors dissolved off into patterns all
around her for ariana grande I did a
similar process where I painted her and
put her in a giant pool of liquid paint
but meat is best known for her dimension
collapsing style of painting figures and
scenes when I'm painting I'm capturing a
mapping of light I paint in the shadows
I paint in the Hilah
and I exaggerate them and make the darks
darker and the lights lighter which is
quite counterintuitive a lot of people
think that if I'm going to be flattening
space that that must mean that I am
neutralizing the shadows then perhaps
painting the shadows lighter to match
with the rest of the environment in fact
I'm just doing the opposite by pushing
them so far apart it makes it harder for
your eye to see where the natural
shadows and contours are and instead you
just see my painted brushstroke
representation of the shadow I have to
really follow the contours of the object
and when it comes to clothing in the
drapery I have to be really careful that
my brush doesn't disturb the drapery if
I'm painting it on a mannequin I need to
be sure that my brush doesn't dent a
peek in the clothing and then create a
new area of shadow the way I apply paint
depends on the aesthetic I'm going for
oftentimes I'll dip my brush into
multiple colors and then just do these
big strokes that combine the brushstroke
hair texture of all these different
colored striations going through it if
I'm doing something in a street art
style often just be straight white and
straight black together and super high
contrast I'll use brushes that you would
normally see artists painting with I'll
also use giant froome's
if I'm painting a wall that's 36 feet
wide and I have to make it look like an
impressionist painting I can't be using
a brush that wide I need to have
something that's on an 8 foot handle and
just sweeping it onto the walls the
illusion is most effective when I am
painting things that have extreme depth
to them the more 3d an object is the
more startling the collapse of space
appears whereas if I'm painting
something that has shallow depth and I
try to flatten it you see that little
bit of depth and it's not as convincing
it's almost paradoxical that to really
flatten something I have to start with
something that has extreme volume human
bodies have a lot of volume to work with
I use different paints on the skin than
I use for everything else there's
usually very little surface area of the
body that I'm physically painting on
it's usually just the face and the
in that case I am always using on the
body a special paint that is safe for
the skin but learning how to apply paint
to a person to make it look like a
painting of a person took a lot of trial
and error earlier in my career as I was
developing this style I wanted to see
how lifelike I could make the paintings
sometimes if I paint a subject too
smoothly and too close to reality
there's an uncanny valley effect where
it just looks like a human who's wearing
too much makeup rather than a painted
portrait her work can at times seem like
a Banksy style street art come to life
or an impressionist portrait made real
but that's because it's a collaboration
with her models when a painter is
painting on canvas they're capturing one
particular expression of the model or in
cuba's and perhaps multiple expressions
at once but it's a single image and it's
largely decided by the artist how that
person will be portrayed and my work I'm
painting physically on the person and so
even though it might be my decision
where I'm putting down the brushstrokes
and the color palette the human still
shines through and in the photography
there's micro-expressions there's the
look in the eyes and so I am it's really
fun about that is that people are
dynamic and you can capture interesting
things on video that you might not
ordinarily be able to capture with a
two-dimensional painting one of my
favorite paintings was of a friend of
mine from high school who proposed to
his girlfriend as living street-art that
was a real proposal she had no idea it
was coming and I'm really glad she said
yes the painting was done in a black and
white street art style and the two of
them walking down through an alley in
San Francisco among all the street art
blended in perfectly amazingly it was a
class project that kicked off feeds
artistic career it wasn't until the end
of my senior year of college when I was
about to graduate with my degree in
political science that I developed this
technique for painting on shadows and I
realized there's something here I have
to follow it and I kept pushing it until
finally I was able to make a
three-dimensional space appear
two dimensional before that I hadn't
seriously done any painting I never
taken a photography course and I had to
teach myself these skills through the
process of developing the illusion when
I did my first experiments with painting
shadows on people I didn't quite
understand what's going on because when
I photographed it
my friend looked like he was a
two-dimensional painting I thought any
camera I was pointing at it was broken
because it made no sense
my friend was 3-dimensional in front of
me but on the screen it looked like it
was a work of art I decided I don't know
what this is but I have to play with it
and see what happens and do more and
develop it I remember showing my
professor the photos of my painted
friend and he completely didn't get it
and he told me that this looks like he
could have made it in Photoshop and if
that's the case maybe you should have
just made it in Photoshop
he thought it seemed like a lot of extra
work to physically paint on a person
when I could get a similar effect doing
something easier and I tried explaining
to my professor that that wasn't the
point this is about painting light and
shadow and capturing it within this
space and I decided that I didn't really
care what he thought I needed to see for
myself since then she's pushed her
technique developing ways to cover
entire three-dimensional objects even
rooms so that they appear to be
flattened paintings from any angle I'm
interested in playing with perception
creating something that looks one way
but in reality is something completely
different
finding different layers to peel back
and look through Meads most recent work
as a project is one of google's artists
and residents she's painting an
installation scene and props for the
tech companies Los Angeles offices and
later to be explored in augmented
reality I'm working with Google to
capture my artwork using light-filled
technology so that the 3d nature of it
in real life can then be preserved
digitally as well the capture can later
be turned into an immersive augmented
reality experience but it wouldn't be a
mead piece without another layer or two
first the installation was digitally
mapped using Google's deep view method
we captured it with light field and then
we looked at what the digital depth maps
will look like of that space different
depths are
presented computationally in different
colors it's what's known as a depth map
I'm then taking that digital depth map
from the light field and painting it
directly on top of the space and then
we're going to be capturing that again
with light field it's quite meta it's
going from the physical 3d to the
computational photography's
interpretation of the 3d painting that
back onto reality and then capturing it
once more something that's then
surprising me is that no matter what
type of style I painted the effect will
still appear to be a two-dimensional
painting it's not reserved for
impressionistic style it also works in a
street art style pop art style and now
in this project I'm using a digital
imaging style of a classic depth map to
turn it not into a painting but into
something that looks like a
two-dimensional computer graphic and of
course there will be a painted figure in
the scene as well
that's where Meade finds her work
resonates most with viewers there's
aspects of the final image that I'm able
to influence but not necessarily able to
control and that has to do with how the
model is holding themselves in front of
the camera that could do with the
micro-expressions the tension in the
face the look in the eyes and so much of
that has to come forth through the model
it's almost like a collaboration because
it's both parties coming together to
create this look in the future Meade is
hoping to push her work with other
collaborations I'm interested in
collaborate with more scientists
engineers mathematicians people working
in these different fields to create art
work together
you
[Music]